security camera footage shows the
suspect wearing military-style fatigues
with his face covered his printed done
corridors before firing shots from a
semi-automatic pistol police say the
attack was planned
he had a swastika on his clothes when he
committed the ACT but when we seized the
symbol it was no longer attached to his
clothes he's kept them somewhere else we
saw everything the clothes he wore the
weapons he used the objects the knives
everything
officers say the 16 year old suspect
targeted his former school before moving
to a second School a few minutes away
victims had little time to escape
he had Direct access to the staff room
during break time he surprised them and
attacked nine teachers who received help
but two died
parents arriving at the scene hoped for
the best
I got here quickly and took my daughter
the daughter of her friend and another
student who had asked me for help I put
them all in the car and we drove away
the governor of espirita Santo has
declared three days of mourning
a tragedy this is a tragedy a tragedy
where we need to show solidarity and
stand with those who were directly
affected and that is what we're doing
here
the suspect is in custody authorities
say he's a military officer's son and
used registered weapons
this has led to questions about Brazil's
gun laws firearm ownership increased
five-fold since 2019 when laws were
relaxed some say increased availability
of weapons could make mass shootings
more common
Barbara engopa Al Jazeera